-Welcome back.
There's a lot of stuff you can
read in your day-to-day life,
and not all of it's interesting.
But I think it's time
that we change that.
We're gonna liven up some of the
most boring things imaginable
by turning them
into unforgettable songs
in a new game called
"Auto Tune-Up."
♪♪
-♪ Auto-Tune Up, yeah ♪
♪ No, no, no, no ♪
-I'm gonna need some help,
so joining me now is
the one and only Jamie Foxx!
Oh, come on, pal.
-What up, baby?
-J.F., I'm so happy
that you're here doing this.
You know I love you, man.
You're the best.
-Yeah, I'm in the house like
furniture. Down like gravity.
You know how we go.
-[ Laughs ] Here's how
this game's gonna work.
We'll each be given
a random boring paragraph,
and the words will appear
on screen.
Our job is to turn it into
an awesome song
with the help of auto-tune.
You ready for this?
-Got it.
And I love that jingle y'all got
at the end --
with that chord at the end.
-That was good, right?
That was a little jazzy.
Alright, I'm up first.
Let's see what I'm auto-tuning.
Amazon review
of a screwdriver set.
Okay.
Alright, give me the sound.
Let me try it.
♪♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Mmm ♪
Okay.
-Baby.
When we come out this
quarantine,
we going on the road.
-[ Laughs ]
I have no idea what tune that
was, but we'll do something.
-Hey, that's straight rock
and soul -- rock and soul.
-Come on.
Alright, Jamie, now it is time
to see what you get.
Here we go.
It's Jamie's turn.
Okay, this is
the DVD copyright warning.
This is the warning that comes
on when you first play a DVD.
♪♪
-[ Laughing ]
Oh, my gosh.
What did you end it with?
Did you say "ding-dong"?
-♪ 506 ♪
♪ Offender ♪
-[ Laughing ]
Offender. Oh, my gosh.
-Got to get that diction,
though.
-That's what it is?
That's the secret?
♪ Offender ♪
[ Laughs ]
Dude, that's the best.
I would buy that jam.
Now, this might turn.
Let's see what I'm singing.
Combos ingredients list.
This is the list of ingredients
on a bag of Combos. Okay.
-A bag of Combos.
-Here we go. Alright.
♪♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ And then you got some ♪
♪♪
[ Both laughing ]
-Yo, you killing that.
I popped something.
-You alright?
-Yeah, I popped something,
a vein.
-At one point, you hit 'em
with the Rick Ross R&B.
-[ Laughs ]
I keep going into, like, Montel
Williams, whatever I keep doing.
♪ Pick up the Combos,
put your hands up ♪
Some vein started throbbing
and went up into my brain there.
I had a little seizure there,
but I'm back to normal.
-Take a couple aspirin off
of that right after this.
Take a couple aspirin and thin
the blood.
-Appreciate it.
Here we go, Jamie.
Last song for you.
Here we go.
Article on how
to spider-proof a shed.
Here we go. This is it.
This is the song of the summer.
Let's hear it.
♪♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
-Oh, my goodness!
How do you do that?
I love it.
-And notice how I put in a
little Spanish
just so we could --
international, when we go to the
bigger platforms.
-That's genius.
It's global.
-'Cause it's about encompassing.
-That's exactly what it is, and
that was unbelievable.
That is a --
♪ You're a two-time offender ♪
-♪ Offender ♪
-[ Laughs ] That's amazing.
More with Jamie Foxx
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Thanks for playing that.